anonymous why the thumbnail are you
trying to make me fail no not November
[Music]
hey guys welcome to another episode of
responding to your comments why wait
let's just get started
I think I know what no Knut November is
now are you doing that for a cause
because then I'll support you but if
you're just doing no Knut November to
prove something to yourself that's cool
hope you're not in a relationship
because that's gonna be rough I will say
doing a simple task that you can stick
to for example like brushing your teeth
with the opposite hand that you're used
to proving it to yourself that you can
be strict and disciplined stick to it
can actually translate to other areas of
your life and then you'll start seeing
your ability to be disciplined in going
to the gym and following a diet maybe no
not November is exactly what the doctor
ordered I know that's not no weird I'm a
triplet have you ever delivered
multiples any stories Cortney I've never
delivered triplets
I've never even delivered twins although
my sister has twins they're my nephews
and I play with them all the time
there's wearing glasses make your
eyesight worse no Gabrielle that's like
a common myth that you hear from people
I think the misconception started off
when someone uses eyeglasses or let's
say not using eyeglasses and they think
their visions fine they put on
eyeglasses everything seems like it's HD
and amazing and they take the glasses
off and all of a sudden it looks worse
that's because you now got used to
seeing normally with the glasses ass
seat what are the current opinions on
tattoos in medical school I have a
sleeve on my left arm but everything can
be covered would this be an issue I
don't think it's an issue especially
right now medical school is becoming
incredibly progressive I have a tattoo
it's not shown it's obviously coverable
that's ideal just because all humans
have their own implicit biases we
undergo some implicit bias training to
be more aware of them but they exist so
why create an opportunity for a tattoo
on your neck or on your face that
patients are gonna have to confront that
and deal with it you're bringing another
barrier into the doctor-patient
relationship and I'm not saying that
they're right for doing that but it's
gonna happen if you're aware of that and
you understand the consequences by all
means get that tattoo I'm a fan and send
me a picture because I want to
civil Duckling 4n I don't know what 4n
means but I like you civil duckling is
it weird to sneeze seven times in a row
is it weird weird meeting unusual yes
it's unusual but most people do sneeze
in multiples and my buddy Leonard
Sherman aka the sausage maker he sneezes
like seven eight nine ten times in a row
he literally sounds like a dog he's a
quorum it chills should I take prenatal
vitamins if I'm trying to get pregnant
yeah Cora you really should with in
prenatal vitamins you have a nutrient
called folate or folic acid you'll see
sometimes that's really important to the
for the development of your child's
neurological development I generally
don't like supplements and I tell people
all the time that yeah you shouldn't
really be taking a multivitamin unless
there's a medical reason for it trying
to make a baby and conceive you should
be taking prenatal vitamins that's a
medical reason there is proof there is
research on that so I do recommend
prenatals can you please do a collab
with david dobrik or another youtuber
who you have in collab with natalie i
want to do this so bad I do have one
collab lined up with a very popular
youtuber I've already collapsed with
Ricky Dillon Ava Gutowski and Gabby
Hannah but if you have a youtuber you
want me to collab with my biggest piece
of advice because I don't necessarily
feel comfortable just going out and
saying okay collab with me they get so
many requests as is I don't want to be
annoyance if you want to tweet at them
or leave comments when their YouTube
videos that you think they should collab
with me I'll jump in I'll retweet your
tweet I'll comment perhaps we can get a
line of conversation going Kristen Musa
what are your opinions on routine infant
circumcision in the u.s. I don't know
how routine it is I guess that you do
have to sort of deny it if you don't
want it to happen I don't think that
there's a lot of great evidence to
support routine circumcision I think
it's a surgery it has risks it has
benefits and it should be up to the
parents to make a decision on what they
want to happen to their child what I do
when I'm functioning as a pediatrician
as a family medicine doctor I have a
detailed discussion with my parents when
I say parents I need my patients who are
parents there's not a lot of great
benefits we're seeing some decreases and
what we call balanitis which is
inflammation of the glans of the penis
there's been some research on showing
decreased transmission of
HIV and those who are circumcised it's
not evidence that's mind-blowing or even
life-changing there's certainly side
effects if the procedure goes wrong and
it can go wrong things can go wrong in
these procedures I've seen botched
circumcision just think about how bad
that is I don't think it's mutilation
I've heard some people discuss that
because there are some benefits but it's
just important to weigh those benefits
first the harms for each individual
patient and not just make this a routine
procedure what are your thoughts on
anesthesia awareness is it possible to
wake up during surgery
evie I've heard of this it's really
scary I can't imagine if I'm cut open
and then I wake up and I feel everything
I've heard of instances of this
happening knowing how true it is because
it is subjective is hard to know I mean
I believe all my patients it's really
scary and something that scares me and
I've thought about this what if the
anesthesia since part of anesthesia is
amnesia meaning that you forget what
happened also what if during your
surgery
you wake up or you you don't wake up but
you feel everything but then when the
surgery is over and you wake up from the
anesthesia you have amnesia so you'll
remember the surgery squid lava why do I
have such a short attention span maybe
because you're a squid lava I don't know
I need to ask you so many questions the
fact that you asked this one question
without any punctuation in the YouTube
section tells me that you definitely
having a short attention span my thing
is when someone comes in with a
complaint of short attention spans
I don't like jumping to a disorder
because what that does is that
encourages you to label yourself as a
person who has let's say ADHD it now
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
that's gonna keep you from reaching your
goals i instead like to focus on what
are your symptoms what can we do to help
them what can we try from the most
conservative to then increasing stepwise
approach that's my thought process on it
I hope you were able to despite your
short attention span listen to my
blabbing I like your logic I like your
logic not rachana because you left that
quote in order to give me a compliment
because you knew I'll use it in this
video so that you get airtime so well
done I like your logic before I take a
test I study and know most of the
information ball I'm taking one I seem
to blank out what causes this can I
and mark this does happen this has
happened to me I mean I've taken
hundreds if not thousands of tests in my
career in trying to become a doctor
something that you may be doing that
could be contributing to this is not
simulating a testing environment I'll
explain what I mean I like for you to
set up with a timer however long you
need for your test give yourself a test
don't know the answers practice
recalling that information recalling
that information is a different type of
memory and you need to practice that can
we please see pictures of teenage dr.
Mike Amy dear you don't want to see it
you don't want to see it
spiky Jersey Shore Pauly D hair in your
face obnoxious look teenage years are
awkward years it's not easy to get
through them without some embarrassing
pictures floating to the surface what's
your take on birth control for teens to
use to regulate periods
Tannis sometimes this makes sense I know
a lot of people worry about taking birth
control about increases and risks of
certain cancers and while there's some
truth to that there's also some
decreases in cancer rates when taking
birth control so it's always a trade-off
between the benefits and the harms
especially when you're talking about
hormonal treatments I have used birth
control in teens to help regulate
periods that was a treatment that I've
done in the past is it right for
everybody absolutely not it's an
individual decision that you should make
as a team with your doctor and if your
teen with your parent I can pop my big
toes multiple times in a row you should
put that on your resume it's awesome dr.
Mike can you make a video about
concussions more information needs to be
known about the century I agree with you
in fact two days ago I was playing
basketball with my nephew I snuffed him
because I'm the block master I fell but
I felt so bad that I actually have a
bruise on my hip bruise on my shoulder
my head got right a little bit and I
think I had a mild concussion cuz I had
a headaches like three days after that I
was initially gonna specialize in sports
medicine after my family medicine
residency I've attended the conference's
on concussions I've looked at the
research on this so I will be making a
dedicated video just for you what is an
unhealthy amount of time on your phone a
day for your eyes or your brain I know
it's not your specialty just curious on
what you thought Robert I'm curious
whose specialty you think it is to talk
about
cellphones I'll tell you what I tell
parents of teenage children and my guess
middle school children it's to limit
screen time to two hours a day outside
of what you get in school what we found
is not causation but a correlation which
means two events happening
simultaneously those who spend more than
two hours of screen time a day have side
effects as a result struggles with
mental health some visual issues try and
limit it to two hours a day live in real
life spend time laughing with your
friends doing stuff outside the world is
beautiful and God I sound like I'm 90
years old two hours that's your answer
just found your videos and I'm obsessed
I don't think it's healthy guess what on
the contrary it is healthy you're
watching a doctor break up
misinformation teach you real stuff
about your health give you some guidance
allow you to have fun get your
neurotransmitters going win win win win
win
please don't spend five hundred hours a
day watching my videos see how's a trick
statement because there's no 500 hours
in a day I was exaggerating and you know
that because you're educated if
radiation can cause cancer
how come doctors use it to try and
shrink the cancer cell radiation is
lethal to cells now cancer cells
ourselves too so if we can target the
radiation very accurately and now we
have amazing technology courtesy of
radiation specialists physics
specialists when you can target
radiation at the tumor cell you can
actually kill those cancer cells fan
halter is it normal for me to be able to
touch my head to my butt
okay I'm not flexible so I can't do it
you could be hyper mobile I have
patients through the hypermobile joints
well that could be a sign of a clinical
condition like Marfan's or some other
ones what I know about people who are
hyper mobile is they're more susceptible
to injuries you're supposed to have a
limited range of motion and when you go
past that physiologic range of motion
you can actually cause damage talk to
your doctor about what you can be doing
and where you have to exercise caution
what do you give first good news or bad
news Cameron when I receive news I want
to hear the bad news first because I'll
take that shock and then hopefully the
good news will make me feel better and
I'll forget about all about the shock
when I'm delivering the news I think I
like to do the same thing making people
wait for bad news can increase the
anxiety related to that bad news
therefore making the person more
susceptible
negative effects that's my medical way
of thinking about it I saw my first
mental health professional today can we
talk about how weird it is to talk about
inner feelings with a total stranger
Stephanie you're a hundred percent right
it's hard to talk to a complete stranger
it takes time to build a rapport and
we're not gonna give you a diagnosis and
a treatment plan right away from the
first visit takes time for you to be
able to share things create a connection
make sure to stay positive carry a
personal sense of responsibility and
know that there is no obstacle that is
too big for you to overcome if you come
with that mindset you will do better
with your outcomes I know many of you
are incredibly passionate about mental
health so click up here for my mental
health video and tell me what you think
do you have a question leave it down
below in the comments because clearly I
like answering them as always stay happy
and healthy